okay our next speaker is Marcus Mobius
from our lap and he will talk about the
effects of news aggregators and social
media on online consumption all right so
thank you so this project is joined also
with Susan easy so you're kind of
getting a double feature and what we are
trying to do is what we're trying to
understand and this project is recent
changes with reason I mean during the
past five years roughly in the way we
consume online news and you know it used
to be the case that you know we consumed
news pretty much the same way as we
consumed paper newspapers we went to the
New York Times website and then we look
through their new website did a similar
setup as a paper edition the front page
is pretty similar to the page one and
then the various sections but now
increasingly use intermediaries to
actually access this news in particular
content a news aggregator such as Google
News and in recent couple of years
social media such as Facebook so that
our friends basically filter the news
for us and to give you some numbers this
is from a recent survey from Pew
Research the top 25 new sites in the US
receive about thirty percent of that
traffic from Google News okay so almost
every third user is referred to from
google news that's an enormous number
facebook is increasingly becoming
important there's a sort of strong
upward trend and Huffington Post for
example gets about eight percent of its
users from facebook referred and New
York Times is six percent already too
okay and that has been increasing since
last year the last few years now there
are different opinions on sort of what
this means for the newspaper industry
okay and on the one extreme you have
people like Rupert Murdoch who hate news
aggregators and over the years here
call them so I had to remember those
choice words hehe called him parasites
vampires content kleptomaniacs and tech
worms of the internet intestines so
suddenly sort of a rich set of words
there and on the other hand you have
people like equally outspoken people
like Arianna Huffington who who defend
the business model of news aggregators
okay so what are these two positions
well the people who support news
aggregators and say that well they send
traffic new traffic more traffic to
online news sites so basically the
volume of news goes up now on the other
hand you know people like murdoch would
say that well but users can skim the
headlines on google news say they don't
have to actually go to the website so
it's not clear that volume actually goes
up so this is a sort of empirical
question does volume go up or not the
other one is you know it's often said
that these new media's I mean these new
intermediaries they basically give new
readers because you find out about a new
newspaper which your magazine which you
didn't know about before okay but you
know the worry then is that maybe these
readers maybe you get some new readers
but the older readers may become more
fickle because you know they are less
loyal to your publication and they are
more easily switch and you know also
like you know there's there's a there's
a sort of concern that newspaper lose a
curator role in in sort of you know it
used to be that the New York Times
provided you with sort of a set of
articles they consider it important and
now you know Google News tells you go to
page three of the New York Times you
don't even know that this was how the
New York Times ranked those different
articles okay now together these
questions we use a an experiment a
classy experiment use the fact that in
november two thousand nine in Google
News France introduced a feature which
allowed for news aggregation of local
news okay so up to that time Google News
France was mainly useful for news
aggregation of national news but after
November you could input your zip code
into into a field it's shown below here
and once you inputted that zip code
um it customized your local news for
your town or for your region okay and so
what we can do is we can compare the
people who signed up who signed up for
this for this for this for the service
so who suddenly have local news
aggregation and we you know we call them
the treatment users and we compare them
with a set of control users who do not
sign up okay and we sort of carefully
constructed these control users to
select users who live geographically
close to the treatment users who
consumers similar who use Google uses
similar extent and also consume a
similar amount of local news okay and
this was all done with people who use
bing toolbar which is sort of a nice
data set lots of you know social social
science research is done Microsoft using
that kind of data and basically sort of
reconstructed you know set of a few
thousand users some who signed up and
some who don't sign up before they sign
up the two groups look exactly the same
except that the control users basically
don't have any local news aggregation
and the treatment users have and sort of
then we can compare what happens so the
first question maybe the most important
one is volume what happens to volume of
glocal news and so you know the zero and
that graph is a sign update that's when
people sign up the red graph is always
the control users and the blue graph is
the other treatment users and you can
see that there's a big spike at the
moment they sign up their consumption of
local news this is local news
consumption on the left in terms of page
views on the right you have local news
consumption terms of 12 time how much
time they actually spend in front of the
browser and you can see that this big
spike but then importantly that effect
lasts it doesn't dissipate and in fact
we followed it over like eight weeks and
it doesn't dissipate it's a lasting
effect that people who sign up they
consume more local news afterwards then
then the treatment users okay so that
would go against Rupert Murdoch for non
local news consumption we don't see an
effect so the control and the treatment
users are the same which we would kind
of expect because you know for the non
local news nothing
really change with Google News however
you know the people who use google news
there afterwards seem to like uber news
more so they you know go more often to
the Google News homepage now what about
the new readers you know we know that
volume goes up but do the readers become
more fickle now this is looking at the
unique outlets per user and so you see
before the sign update the control and
treatment users have the roughly the
same number of newspapers they navigate
to in a typical week but afterwards this
is local newspapers only afterwards you
see that the treatment users have about
sixteen percent more outlets they
navigate to ok so certainly they find
out about new new new new sources ok but
what you can do is you can actually
distinguish between old news and new use
and when you do that you'll actually
find that you'll actually find that the
page views both for old news and for new
use goes up ok so it's not the case that
they substitute away from the old news
sources and they are less loyal to them
it's in fact the case that they you know
everything is consumed more alright so
the kind of one one one caveat in this
where you know Murdoch might be right is
the fact that we found that that in
terms of the index page views the number
of times the share of time you spend on
the index page that's kind of for
example the home page of the local
newspaper that goes down and goes down
by about you know fifteen percent here
20-22 between fifteen and twenty percent
for the treatment user so basically the
treatment users are much more likely to
navigate directly to new sources they
spend less time so basically the curator
role of newspapers indeed does decrease
okay so there's some evidence for that
so just to conclude you know we have
done this you know we found evidence for
this and you know this is just an
example of what kind of data you can use
available here at Microsoft to like do
these kind of big data analysis but
otherwise very difficult to do right hey
Thank You Marcus
okay we have time for a couple of
questions yes I hear you but I guess
they have to just their overall news
consumption just go up altogether yes it
does it actually also goes up for the I
didn't show you those but it also goes
up for the non local news but basically
we found that dad goes up because they
use Google News more so it's completely
explained by the increased use of the
Google News homepage whereas the local
news goes up both conditioning
unconditionally on the Google News
homepage use more questions yeah
offering newspapers the kind of
newspaper you read determines your
political orientation do you see any
cross border crossing between people
that they used to read only one type of
newspapers yeah so so this is something
we are we are working on right now
because so far you know what we but be
used for this project I just showed you
the data for was basically just local
non-local classification and that's very
easy to do when you go at political
orientation you actually have to like
look well you can either classify
newspapers you know using using some
other index there's also like text-based
classifiers but you can for example go
to the opinion pages and you know some
work was done for example by Matt cans
going like you know you go to the
opinion pages of Wall Street Journal New
York Times and this text based
classifiers can sort of you know
determine whether this is a left-leaning
or right you know more right-leaning
newspaper and so you can use these kind
of approaches and that's something we
are looking right now especially because
we want to look more at the social media
aspect and and that's going to be
important okay thank you Marcus